what does a drone hack look like
it only takes a few seconds to penetrate
a victim's computer the hacker will
place equipment on the Drone weighing
only 61 grams Raspberry Pi zero battery
radio PA wireless adapter
the Drone must be fast and small like
for example fpv the Drone flows up to
the victim's window spoofing the signal
from the wireless keyboard or Mouse
this is the mouse Jack vulnerability
the hacker pretends to be a keyboard and
sends the victim a keyboard command the
victim doesn't have time to understand
anything so the hacker gets full access
and can do whatever he wants
to learn more about this threat and
protection methods see the full video
link in the comments